uh some more breaking news from the uk  health security agency on omicron now uh  it has found that evidence shows that  omicron is growing much faster than  delta in england omicron is projected to  become the dominant variant in the uk by  mid-december that is based on current  trends and new data suggests that the  vaccine protection against mild  symptomatic disease from omicron may be  substantially reduced effectiveness  against severe disease is still unknown  but is expected to be higher boosters  showed good effectiveness although with  some reduction compared to delta so that  from the uk health security agency which  has been meeting this afternoon omicron  growing much faster than delta in  england projected to become the dominant  variant by the middle of the month and  vaccine protection may be substantially  reduced against mild symptomatic disease